i'm here at peaches which is a fried
chicken sandwich spot in brooklyn they
have a couple of different sandwiches
different levels of spice i'm not that
great with spicy foods but hopefully
i'll be okay let's see
the regular was fine i feel like i could
eat the whole thing of that
the
middle one was probably at my edge
this one i don't even know
oh my god
so why is my brain telling me that my
mouth is on fire while my producers are
better than me this is enjoyable still
for me
and what can i do to ease the pain
to answer those questions we're gonna
have to brush up on some chemistry and
dig into some neuroscience don't touch
your eyes don't touch your eyes
so the burning sensation watery eyes
coughing and sweating that we survived
back at the restaurant has to do with
this chemical compound
c18h27no3 or capsaicin
it's the active component of many chili
peppers and an irritant for animals like
us to learn more about how it interacts
with our nervous system i called up
neuroscientist federica genovese she
told me that your lips tongue throat and
even your nose and eyes have nerve
endings that contain special proteins
called receptors to detect pain once
capsizing binds to it it opens up and
works like a switch when it binds to
them it turns them on and generates a
tiny electrical current the building
block of the brain's language that
electrical signal is what gets
translated into that burning sensation i
felt while eating hot chicken sandwiches
the amount of capsaicin a chili pepper
has affects the intensity of that signal
which is where the scoville heat scale
comes into play it goes from zero heat
units or no spice like with a bell
pepper all the way up to 16 million for
pure capsaicin extract with jalapenos
cayenne and ghost pepper in between this
is the extra hot rub that they put on
the sandwich so let's see how i do with
this
that ghost pepper at the one million
heat unit mark felt like fire on my
tongue
and for my brain oh my god it kind of
was the receptors that bind capsaicin
also respond to things that might burn
you like a hot cup of coffee everyone
wondered why we refer to spicy foods as
hot my face feels really really
really hot this is why oh my god the
nervous system is using the same danger
information highway for multiple threats
whether they're thermal or in the case
of capsaicin chemical once these
receptors are activated the electrical
signal that's generated travels through
the trigeminal nerve up to the brain
specifically to the sensory cortex which
processes information about spiciness
that is really really painful the
signals also get shuttled to the limbic
system which processes information about
rewards and threats
as part of that threat in pain
processing these signals end up in the
hypothalamus which is part of the limbic
system the hypothalamus turns on the
adrenal glands which release adrenaline
and control our fight or flight response
so when we eat spicy foods we get a
small adrenaline rush some people really
likes going on a roller coaster and have
this rush some other people really likes
to have the rash from spicy food and as
with riding roller coasters it gets
easier with experience the more you eat
spicy foods the less you'll feel it
because your receptors become less
sensitive federica also told me that the
more you eat them the more pleasant
experiences you might associate with
spicy foods which could also affect your
perception you have the association of
this pleasuring sensation of the spicy
food associated with whatever you are
eating that increases your experience in
general but even if you love turning up
the heat too much could be dangerous so
don't overdo it you might activate
protective reflexes like sneezing
coughing sweating gagging vomiting or
worse i once mistook a pepper for a
sun-dried tomato and
it didn't end well that's because those
capsaicin binding receptors are almost
everywhere including all the passage and
the exit of the food so basically the
body sees too much capsaicin as a toxin
it needs to get rid of too much could
even send you to the hospital plants
develop capsizing within their seeds as
a mechanism of defense so that animals
will not eat their fruits so if it's too
spicy milk can help ease the immediate
pain whole milk works really well the
reason boils down to the chemistry of
capsaicin the molecule especially this
part right here is hydrophobic meaning
it doesn't dissolve well in water that's
why drinking water won't help much it'll
just slosh the capsaicin around but milk
and other dairy products like cottage
cheese and ice cream are rich in a
protein called cassane which is better
at dissolving capsaicin keeping it away
from your pain receptors that's why many
spicy dishes often have a fatty
component like coconut milk or heavy
cream you know without a scientific
knowledge we already included
the remedy for spiciness within most of
the spicy dishes but if you're thinking
of reaching for some refreshing beer to
wash down the spice don't do that
i think beer is not a good idea because
it has carbonation and alcohol both of
them are irritants so they both are
going to activate the pain system at the
same time so next time you eat spicy
food remember to use science to your
advantage
and just in case keep some milk or ice
cream on hand to help you ease the pain
oh